i'm from jersey originally but i ended
up in seattle that's what happens when
you have warrants in new jersey
in seattle miraculously
and i was doing comedy i was 1995 i was
a [ __ ] criminal
uh and i get to seattle and i find this
[ __ ] dude with a boston hat
he's got a bus and have to club and i go
that's my [ __ ] dude right there
because you're up there with a bunch of
[ __ ] rednecks you know whatever they
are
and he hit it off and we became friends
and roommates and he covered my ass
every weekend
so we're there about three weeks three
years and we're about to leave
he's gonna go to la
september 25th or something and i'm
going to follow him but i was background
i was on the probation so i couldn't
leave by the way from seattle i had
problems with them
[Laughter]
we get like fifty dollars a show nobody
had money
so josh manages his bar and he goes
the boss the yankees are playing the
maritals
and when the mariners with the yankees
come to town everybody drops a bunch ago
and the bar has the money there on
saturday night
30 grand
this is your chance to shine
[Laughter]
so josh has a gig in idaho so it's me
and louise
the alarm is there the money just go
back i don't know how you're going to
get it now so i wait
11 30. now i'm doing i'm doing like a
comedy show i gotta a rather [ __ ]
thing
you learn how to [ __ ] multitask
so
[ __ ]
i kick the door down right like a metal
door
when you're broke
you get the strength of 10 dead iranians
i was [ __ ] strong i was hungry i
ain't [ __ ] around i'm moving this bar
like mary magdalene
[Applause]
but i learned growing up in jersey you
don't need to be a safe cracker just rob
the safe bring it home and call the
welder right so
i watched the movie thief james dodd
tremendous 1980 granted tonight right
now so
i go to pick up the safe the safe way is
ten thousand [ __ ] time
okay marry magnum through a little
blessing
like the django unchained
[ __ ] down the stairs i can feel
my heart bumping and i have to push it
out the door i'm pushing the foot and
lands on the [ __ ] concrete i go out
moving the lips got the trunk open i did
all the [ __ ] heavy work here
and what do i see cop cars apart
in the parking lots feeding people but
they don't know we're robbing the joint
[ __ ] idea
they're out there with the speed though
like [ __ ]
[Applause]
opens up i don't know how i opened this
[ __ ] save up
and there's eight hundred dollars
beforehand
what are you laughing about i can launch
you for a year
yeah a couple things i remember when
they were
first of all
we called him frankie the lip and when i
say we it was joe i you know
because uh he
look man every now and then he'd get a
flare-up you know
and uh
whenever he had that big [ __ ] sword
he'd walk in and joe would go the limp
[Laughter]
oh it's made me [ __ ] done it
so a couple things you left out a safe
store
one
the
stairs so the office was upstairs
the stairs leading up and down were wood
and so when he rolled it down the stairs
it just went through the stairs
to this thing
i don't know i thought he said we were
going to run the sake
do you know how to get it open
and he goes no i'm going to say robert
got a safe crowd
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying
but then when he called
and he goes and he's always told me
about my personal last name guess what
i go yeah and he goes
what am i supposed to do
with eight hundred dollars worth of
[ __ ] coins
[Laughter]
what do you mean that's what's in the
same
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i suppose but you know how the story
goes
another drink another dollar howler 7
p.m once again i'm breaking up the bugs